facebook macht unglücklich was ihr über
facebook wissen sollte und was
wissenschaftliche studien zu dem
netzwerk sagen was wollen wir euch heute
einen klick vom science fiction facebook
macht unglücklich die plattform facebook
bietet platz für hetze gegen
minderheiten und unterbindet diese kaum
diese sätze wird wohl jeder von euch
schon mal gehört haben aber was ist an
diesen aussagen dran erst mal muss die
vom facebook konsum betroffene
menschenmenge genannt werden es sind 1,5
milliarden menschen die ein facebook
profil besitzen auf 24 stunden kommen
kann eine milliarde was machst du gerade
post größtes problem bei diesem post ist
derzeit vor allem der inhalt
bekanntestes beispiel rechtsradikale
plumpe hetze bezüglich der aktuellen
flüchtlingssituation und was macht
facebook dagegen im dritten punkt der
erklärung der rechte und pflichten von
facebook wird unter anderem folgendes
aufgeführt zitat du wirst keine inhalte
posten die hassreden enthalten
bedrohlich oder pornografisch sind zu
gewalt verleiten oder nackt
darstellungen bzw grafische sowie
sonstige gewalt enthalten
des weiteren wird auch diskriminierung
konkret benannt zitat du wirst facebook
nicht verwenden um irgendwelche
rechtswidrigen irreführenden bösartigen
oder diskriminierenden handlungen
durchzuführen
zitat ende ok aber was macht facebook
denn jetzt dagegen aktuell machen sie
auf jeden fall mehr als in der
vergangenheit bezeichnete zahl dabei ist
dass von januar bis ende juni diesen
jahres 112 prozent mehr postings
gelöscht wurden als im gleichen zeitraum
2014 mehr als 20.000 postings weltweit
in deutschland waren es 188 inhalt der
188 postings seien facebook
nachvollziehen symboliken und
holocaustleugnung gewesen
wie lange es dauert bis von usern
gemeldete beiträge gecheckt und
gegebenenfalls gelöscht werden
auf die antwort werden wir wohl noch
länger warten müssen kommen wir jetzt zu
aussage facebook macht unglücklich
dänischen forschern voll gemacht die
nicht nutzung von facebook nicht nur
glücklicher die wissenschaftler deshalb
in das research institute in kopenhagen
führten eine studie mit 1000
90 probanden durch die teilnehmer wurden
in zwei gruppen eingeteilt die eine
gruppe dürfte eine ganze woche weder
etwas auf facebook posten noch lesen sie
mussten sieben tage lang die hände von
facebook weglassen komplett die andere
gruppe dürfte ihren facebook konsum
fortsetzen und ihren social media
verpflichtung wie gewohnt nachkommen
mike viking leiter des happiness
research institutes äußerte sich zu dem
experiment folgendermaßen zitat ich
hatte erwartet dass wir gar keinen
effekt feststellen würden
zitat ende so kam es allerdings nicht
die nichtnutzer waren eigenen angaben
zufolge wesentlich konzentrierter
entspannter und hätten ihre sozialen
bedürfnisse besser befriedigen können
wenn man facebook nicht nutzt hat es
also doch soziale komponenten besser
gesagt kann man dann sozial und facebook
in einem satz nennen die wissenschaft
konnte was die sozialen bedürfnisse des
menschen angeht erstaunliche parallelen
zu sozialen netzwerken feststellen der
gefällt mir button von facebook wirke
sich direkt auf den nucleus accumbens
aus nucleus accumbens ist der bereich in
unserem gehirn der besser unter dem
namen belohnungszentrum bekannt ist das
heißt was früher eine tafel schokolade
oder noch früher ein erlegtes tier für
uns menschen war ist für viele heute
einfach nur eine simple gefällt mir
angabe ein kleiner button kann so tief
in unserem gehirn sein unwesen treiben
das ist leider noch nicht alles zitat
bei vielen naturvölkern ist die
höchstmögliche strafe menschen
auszustoßen im schlimmsten fall kann das
ein todesurteil sein so der soziologe
der universität gießen eckert vollamt
dieses zitat bringt uns direkt zum
weiteren und sozialen problemen auf
sozialen netzwerken wie facebook mobbing
ausgrenzung über diese themen wird schon
viel geschrieben berichtet gesagt
kleiner denkanstoß wenn ausgrenzung
früher ein reales todesurteil darstellte
was ist es dann heute für uns heute ist
deswegen ja keiner zum tode verurteilt
aber irgendwo werden diese belastungen
da abgeladen wenn ich in physischer dann
wohl in psychischer form
lasst uns in den kommentaren mal
diskutieren über diese thematik bei
sozialen netz
wie seht ihr das sind diese netzwerke
tatsächlich sozial oder eben unsozial
ich bin auf eure meinung gespannt wenn
er von klicks und kein video mehr
verpassen wollt dann kostenlos
abonnieren der button ist hier irgendwo
ansonsten auf jeden fall das nächste
video sehen und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran